[Music]
you know overload just think of all we
see in uber in the paper you know we
found four things that we called the
west winds that hit rapidly growing
companies and push them off track and we
called them the west winds and one was
was having revenues growing much faster
than you can grow talent and just think
of uber which has had as many as 13 of
its top 20 positions unfilled and that
has been having difficulty recruiting
the most talented women because of some
of the cultural issues and when your
talent is not growing at the same rate
as your revenues breakdowns begin to
happen you know a second element of the
west winds is what we call lack of
accountability and you can look at the
culture as it evolved in uber which has
been well reported and say who is really
accountable for the norms and values
deep soulful values of a company in in
is very easy to neglect that in the
context of growth and hype and
excitement and celebrity or a third one
is when you begin to look through these
wins is is what we called lost voices
from the front line and if you look at
for example the loyalty numbers you can
find all over the Internet of lift
versus uber drivers what you find is
that the loyalty of uber drivers is
going down because they're a little bit
frustrated with a lot of the publicity
and with some of the behaviors that
they've observed and they're more
disoriented about the company and so
these west winds hit rapidly growing
companies and what we found is that when
we looked at these unicorns we took 26
unicorns about ten years ago 10 to 12
years ago when we trace them and we
found that virtually a hundred percent
of them in two-thirds of them had slowed
down dramatically and never hit what
people wanted them to over be an example
and second we found that in virtually
all of the cases the deep inner root
cause was not that it was a bad idea in
the first place or the market had gone
away it was actually inner breakdowns
like like this case and all these linked
to the founders mentality of linkage to
the front line maintaining a clear
purpose the first is overcomplicating
what you're trying to do and becoming
greedy and doing too much
and creating mini founder experiences
that make people really want to become
part of it second crisis is is the more
predominant crisis and it's what we call
a stall out so if you think of a company
let's say like Lego which since the
1930s with a great founder company
through three or four generations the
first did in wooden blocks and X brought
it to plastic the next created the
business systems and it was voted the
toy of the Year by the British toy
industry company and British toy
industry and yet the next generation
began to say no what what our core is is
the brand not we're not a toy company
and so they went into many many things
that massively complicated and the
business from theme parks to joint
ventures with Steven Spielberg's and
small theaters to retail endeavors to
plastic watches to books and on and on
and on and it sucked the energy out of
the court and resulted in stall out to a
point where the company had 18 months of
cash left and the solution to that was
to massively reduce complexity exit all
those businesses by the CEO who
courageously went in the organ Vic noot
store well role reported in the press
and it gave the company 12 years he
brought technology into the bricks he
found out who the core customers were
they didn't know there were 400,000
people who are obsessed with Lego they
brought them into the design process and
they did many many things to actually go
back to the essence of what made the
company great in the first place which
was the mission of learning and the
customer desire for toy systems that
would help children create create create
creatively and eBay even even did things
like like take the corporate
headquarters which was in a bright
gleaming new building and brought it
back into the factory in the
distribution center so that's an example
of stall out and that's an example of
company that then had 12 years of very
very good growth as a result of in a
sense finding the key to it where the
founders mentality elements were part of
the PlayBook the third one is free fall
and this is where the business model
really does come into question
and you know nine out of ten companies
that see their business model become
potentially obsolete Blockbuster Video
never make it never make it but some do
some do when you think of what happened
to Marvel Comics and you know the
rebirth of spider-man that was a that
was a company where people weren't
buying comic books anymore and yet a
group of investors and some of the
original employees brilliantly saw that
it could be repurposed around the
stories and the characters for videos
for video games and for movies and
completely changed the business model
but at the essence of that also was Reba
now owned by Disney but at the essence
of that also was actually going back to
say what is our real purpose you know
how do we contact the people at the
front line and how do we create new
owners mindset which they did through
private equity and so when we look when
we look at these three these three
critical crisis periods of stall out
overload and a freefall
we found these elements of the founders
mentality were both previous indicators
of lost lack of losing internal health
that could have been seen earlier and
their second they were elements of the
playbook of rejuvenation so the first
thing to me is I realize and even our
own country America is you know a
country of founders and when you lose
the conscious mentality as a country
you lose something in your soul sucking
insight for me is how breakdowns occur
inside first you know in our bodies if
we're not performing well in sports or
at work or in our life so much of that
is not because we don't know how to hit
a tennis ball or we don't know the
mechanics of our job more often it's
something that's going on we're
distracted we're tired were we're not
feeling healthy something else is
bothering us in the environment and
that's true of companies too I think the
idea that 85% of the breakdowns of
organizations were pre-existing
conditions under the surface like an
iceberg that could have been seen is a
very powerful lens and it's reshaping
how we think about strategy and the deep
root cause
success at Bain and the third theme is
complexity you know when when about 12
years ago I moved to Amsterdam with my
wife and we just came back and we lived
there and when we left we decided that
our lives had been to him through
complex and so we sold half of our
things we cleaned out all of our closets
we stopped all our magazine
subscriptions we did many many many
things to create more of a tabula rasa
and we took nothing with us to a new
country we bought new furniture we got a
new house we made friends there we tried
to learn the language etc and yet now
we've come back to America our
complexity has all crept back in it's
like barnacles that accumulate on a boat
and if that's true for two people who
are self aware of this and control their
lives imagine how true it is for
organisations of thousands of people
dozens of business elements myriads of
departments thousands of products
dozens of geographies that complexity
accumulates and so complexity is a
silent killer of growth that's the third
I think big insight complexity is a
silent killer of growth and it happens
if the level of the company as it did
with Lego that eliminated everything but
the toys when it went back to renew
itself it happens at level of an
organization where power flows into big
corporate centers when it should be at
the frontline it happens at the level of
processes if you read Jeff Bezos recent
shareholder letter on Amazon he talks
about when process becomes the outcome
you're in real trouble and very often I
followed the process is what people say
to protect themselves and it even
happens at the detailed level of
products we look at how some startups
have taken over or or how online banking
with just the simplest stick figure
business model can take over from huge
gigantic multinationals take over a lot
of market share and so to me these three
lessons about the deep inner root causes
are often under the surface and need to
be found the roots of leadership and
humility are in the great founders and
we need more of them and they're the
national treasure and that complexity is
the silent killer
of growth in progress
[Music]